all right we're gonna be in this hour
with the latest on the health of actor
bruce willis a lot of people talking
about this yeah the hollywood star truly
beloved stepping away from his career
because of a medical condition called
aphasia that makes it hard for him to
communicate his daughter rumor revealed
that he has the condition revealed it
just yesterday and she said in a
statement quote this is a really
challenging time for our family we are
moving through this as a strong family
unit and we wanted to bring his his fans
in because we know how much he means to
you as you do to him and that is
definitely true carter evans has more
welcome to the party pal
for plane no holds barred nypd detective
john mcclane in die hard
[Laughter]
to child psychologist dr malcolm crowe
in the sixth sense how often do you see
them
[Music]
all the time
and hardened oil thriller turned
astronaut harry stamper and armageddon
i'm gonna give you three seconds to shut
this bomb down then i'm gonna make you
shoot me few light up the screen quite
like bruce willis you're looking at
something for him
now the 67 year old is stepping away
from the career he loves wednesday his
family said he has aphasia which leads
to the inability to speak and understand
language
roughly 180 000 people in the u.s are
diagnosed every year with the disorder
it's caused by brain damage it could be
a stroke it could be a virus it could be
a tumor there are many causes to affect
that part of the brain cbs news medical
contributor dr david agus says it's
often not reversible and progresses in
different ways you know he could be like
this for many years if this is a
progressive disorder whether it be a
neurologic disorder whether it be a
tumor or others it could progress over
weeks to months to years and so we just
don't know in this case and certainly we
hope and pray that you know he's not you
know suffering or stressed willis's
legendary career spans more than four
decades after his award-winning
performance in the tv series
moonlighting in the late 80s he launched
into super stardom as an action hero he
had an ability to be funny to be
menacing
to be heroic
to be witty eric degens is a tv critic
for npr what's bruce willis's legacy he
could do it all really
and and i think that's one of the things
that was so compelling about him as a
performer is that when you saw him in a
movie sometimes you didn't quite know
what you were going to get from it
and while he has stepped away from
acting we will still be seeing bruce
willis grace our screens in the near
future he's acting in eight movies
currently that are in post-production or
are already completed gail
oh thank you very much carter a lot of
people cheering him on and pulling for
bruce willis the only upside if there is
a upside is that now people will know i
didn't know how to pronounce it i had
never heard of it before so we'll all
become more educated but certainly
wishing him well rooting for bruce
willis one of my all-time favorite
actors so good as eric diggins pointed
out he's so good in everything he does
didn't we love moonlighting we love
moonlighting i even bought the or the
cassette people of a certain age will
remember the cassette of the return of
bruno his album when he was still in the
moonlighting era you remember
i don't but i loved uh pulp fiction yeah
yes we've got now seven more movies
apparently coming along from bruce yeah
different people see them different ways
that's good as eric said good at
everything right